[Music]
you're the biggest movie star in the
world right now
but last week all the talk was about you
running for president is there gonna be
a president Johnson look I think
anything's possible right this is
America everybody is possible yeah I had
a great time Katie Weaver who's a GQ
writer right he came out with that story
and just such a tremendous story well
written very witty and the the intention
wasn't all of a sudden to have the the
talk about me running for president
again right it just happened naturally
happened and here we are here we are
talking about it but were you surprised
how people ran with and it said I like
that idea what has been so flattering
over the past week and really really
humbling and very eye-opening is the
amount of American people who actually
want to see this happen yeah and it
really means so much to me and you know
somebody had asked me earlier well what
makes you think you would be a great
president I don't think I'm president I
know I well I don't well because
politics is not my business and I'm not
a politician I can tell you I feel that
what people are responding to I think
with me is that I have us I do a pretty
good job in terms of leadership but in
terms of galvanizing a lot of people and
bringing them together to get a job done
and to be better but that's what a
president does that is it's one of the
qualities yes of a president and then
people also seem to believe in the
person that you are your morals your
life everything seem to believe in you
that sounds like a leader yeah I
appreciate that I really really do and
again you know the intention wasn't to
spark up the conversation again but you
know now that it's here I I'm really
grateful I appreciate it
you know and I just got to continue to
do what I do again I'm not a politician
I still like putting in the work my own
two hands and sweating every day and
doing that so that's three and a half
years from now we'll see
[Music]